bonjour michel tonini merci d'être avec
nous vous êtes astronautes vous êtes
parti deux fois dans l'espace très très
longue expérience dans le spatial ainsi
responsable du centre des astronautes
européens avec vous on va évoquer
aujourd'hui les conséquences sur le
spatial de la guerre en ukraine on va
lettre détaillée et analyser avec vous
on sait michel tonini que la russie a
suspendu les lancements depuis le
cosmodrome de kourou en guyane française
que s'est il passé depuis quels sont vos
dernières informations sur les
conséquences de sa sanction ayant trait
au spatial
alors on niveau des bons jours tous au
niveau des vols habités les astronautes
et les cosmonautes ont en ce moment dans
la station spatiale internationale et
vous savez que dans cette station des
russes des ukrainiens des américains un
européen qui est né en allemagne et les
opérations continuent normalement est-ce
que l'espace c'est une victime
collatérale de ce qu'ils entendent se
passait sur terre
dans certains domaines oui parce que
comme vous l'avez évoqué les fusées
soyouz de coûts vont s'arrêter donc on
s'en servait c'était très utile pour
envoyer nos satellites dans l'espace
notamment certains sites et les deux
galileo des programmes plus importants
comme exomars risque d'être compromise
c'est que l'examen cette édition assez
unique au monde qui va permettre de
forer le sol de mars trouver des
éléments extrêmement intéressant pour la
connaissance de cette planète et cette
mission à ne peut décoller que tous les
deux ans vu les distances qui change
entre terre et mars et la prochaine
échéance est en septembre de cette année
et l'eau ne sera dans deux ans donc nous
on est vraiment niveau scientifique très
impacté on va revenir sur exomars dans
un instant michel tonini un mot de ce
qu'a dit thierry breton le commissaire
européen aux affaires au marché
intérieur qui a dit que l'europe va tout
faire pour garantir son autonomie
stratégique en matière de lanceurs
est-ce que c'est crédible est ce que en
l'état actuel des choses cette autonomie
stratégique existe
alors il y a aujourd'hui une autonomie
européenne ue d ensuite aux avions à
rien 5 qui a fonctionné pendant des
années de façon très très très très
bonne a été très efficace beaucoup de
sécurité la prochaine série n 6 qui va
décoller en fin de cette année ou
l'année prochaine et on a des lanceurs
plus petits comme vega qui perd
également de prendre prendre le relais
pour les lancements de satellites plus
légers d'eau cette autonomie en
satellite on l'a déjà ce que nous
n'avons pas ces lettres c'est le tonneau
mis en accès des vols habités pour nos
astronautes qui vont dans la station
spatiale et on travaille souvent avec
des ingénieurs européens les ingénieurs
du cnes et les gens du gouvernement pour
pouvoir développer une capsules
compatibles de la fusée ariane 6 et avec
tout cela se pose michel tonini la
question de l'avenir de la station
spatiale internationale pour mémoire
vous l'avez rappelé tout à l'heure c'est
le fruit d'une collaboration assez
intense entre russes japonais américains
et européens canadiens et ce depuis 1988
est ce que au moment où nous parlons
l'avenir de cette station est compromis
à cette division là dit il n'y a rien de
vraiment décidée la seule chose qui soit
officiel pour la station internationale
sait que sa fin de vie sera 2031 donc à
devrait rester encore neuf ans dans
l'espace maintenant si les choses
s'aggravent entre entre les russes et
les américains il pourrait y avoir
éventuellement une séparation du module
russe aurait des modules russes et des
modules américains ce qui sur les
catastrophiques bien sûr parce que cette
station elle travaille en
interdépendance c'est à dire que la
station d'essence de 500 m par jour il
faut la remontée grâce au moteur qui
sont du côté russe et la station vote
tourne en permanence pour être face au
soleil pour la cud pour les panneaux
solaires sont en face au soleil et pour
ça il faut des gyroscopes et des
girondines qui sont dans le secteur
américain dont c'est en effet un concept
de stations où les gens sont en
interdépendance si on ne sait pas il
rencontre ouvre un système différent qui
n'est pas encore vraiment prévu est pas
au point pour remonter le secteur
américain
lorsqu'il va descendre et il faut
trouver aussi un système pour donner
l'alimentation électrique au segment
russe parce que la plupart de
l'alimentation et qu'elle se fait par
ses immenses panneaux solaires qui sont
sur le secteur américain voit si on
sépare la station de morceaux tout le
monde va souffrir et comme les russes
viennent d'envoyer ce module daouk a
communiqué extrêmement cher et qui a été
lancé et les environs six mois je pense
que les russes vont décider de façon
rapide de test de 2 tfc
station spatiale parce que on rappelle
que au moment nous parlons aussi à bord
de la station il ya deux russes quatre
américains et un allemand on pourrait
aussi rappeler michel tonini que moscou
bien avant cette guerre avait annoncé
son retrait de l'ue est de 10 et 16 dès
2025 alors que la nasa souhaite
poursuivre jusqu'en 2030 dans la foulée
il ya cette autre information qui nous
est parvenue la russie annonce un
partenariat avec la chine autour d'une
base lunaire d'abord un orbite puis un
espace habité est ce qu'avec ce qu'ils
entendent se passer là maintenant avec
cette guerre en ukraine les russes ne se
retrouvent pas précipités en quelque
sorte dans les bras des chinois
alors oui les russes ont commencé d'être
coopération avec la chine ya longtemps
puisque vous regardez le système chinois
de la station tiangong 1 ressort
beaucoup la station mir le vaisseau chef
zoulou correspond beaucoup aux vaisseaux
soyouz et les mêmes quand vous regardez
des scaphandres des taïkonautes c'est un
petit peu la copie conforme des
scaphandres des postes notre us donc
cette coopération existe bel et bien il
pourrait y avoir une coopération entre
entre chinois et russes mais il faut
savoir que un grand ingénieur de la nasa
a écrit officiellement il y a quelques
semaines que le but ultime c'est d'aller
sur la lune puis d'aller sur mars à
aller sur la lune pour préparer
l'opération mance et que l'ohio nord ce
n'est cette fois qu avec la coopération
de tous les pays du monde et non pas
avec soin les russes sur les chinoises
soient les amériques à dos tant qu'on
n'aura pas une coopération globale on
pourra pas les semences sur mars
justement comme promis on y revient avec
vos michel tonini on a dit que cette
situation touche assez
durement la mission européenne exomars
censé partir cette année vous avez
rappelé tout à l'heure aussi que cette
mission elle consiste en quoi elle doit
transporte un rover devant forer le sol
martien sauf que exomars d'après les
informations que nous avons des
collaborent d'une fusée russe et son
module de descente au mas est aussi
russes est-ce que ce très vieux projet
qui date quand même de quelques années
est à l'arrêt
alors il n'est pas à l'arrêt pour
l'instant mais on se doute que si les
affaires ne s'arrangent pas entre les
pays d'ici le 20 septembre ce projet est
vraiment compromis et il faut savoir que
si les cons prier pour sept ans il
faudra vraiment attendre deux ans avant
de re décoller pour lancer examen ce qui
je rappelle encore une fois est une
mission unique et ça sera la première
mission au monde qui donnera des secrets
sur le sol de mars et sur ce qu'il y'a
que malte hier dans le dans les
profondeurs de mars et l'arrêt des
collaborations avec la russie dans le
domaine spatial quelles conséquences
michel tonini pour la france
alors la france l'est toujours associé
au segment européen par l' agence
spatiale européenne et ce segment
européen qui est au niveau des vols
habités accroché à la partie américaine
de la station spatiale dont knut notre
coopération est contenu nous asseoir et
européens sur dans l'espace en ce moment
et les des astronautes vivent en
sécurité ce que j'aurai dire c'est que
on parle d'un conflit sur terre qui est
assez important lorsqu'il ya un conflit
sur terre les deux ennemis a et b sont
séparés par une ligne de fond donc les
guerres se passe au niveau d'une ligne
de front qui la une de danger chez nous
astronautes la ligne de front devient
une ligne de l'atmosphère qui fait 100
km et chez nous les ennemis a et b si
son ennemi ils sont du même côté de la
ligne de danger donc nous on a le devoir
de s'entraider et dans l'espace nous
nous aidons et que ce soit des russes
des américains ou des ukrainiens ont
fait le maximum pour que les gens soient
sains et saufs dans cette mission
spéciale voilà qui nous amène michel
tonini a
votre parcours personnel en 1992 vous
avez effectué un vol à bord de la
station russe mir nous sommes trente ans
plus tard est ce que vous vous souvenez
de l'atmosphère à bord est ce que vous
diriez aussi qu'avec six en train de se
passer aujourd'hui nous assistons à un
changement d'époque dans le domaine
spatial
alors moi j'ai mangé d'un vol qui s'est
passé en afrique avec des russes et des
ukrainiens d'ailleurs et tout s'est très
bien passé dans mon vol il y avait une
atmosphère qui était excellente très
studieuse moi c'était mon premier vol
donc j'étais pas très à l'aise au départ
dans le mal ma force ma fonction de de
voyager en apesanteur mais les russes
étaient toujours là pour m'apprendre ce
qu'ils avaient appris depuis les mois et
les mois qui sont passés dans l'espace
donc moi c'était une atmosphère qui
était vraiment
excellente dans mon niveau
donc cet espace de coopération
finalement il faut le maintenir si je
vous suis bien
alors il faut le maintenir parce que
aujourd'hui on veut bien que cette
guerre implique beaucoup de pays avec
des choses qui sont extrêmement graves
au sol mais l'espace habité et le seul
trait d'union qui nous permet d'avoir
ensemble russes américains européens
japonais et même craignant est
d'ailleurs dans la fin du mois de mars
va s'opposer de la station spatiale à
des soyouz dans lequel sera seront un
cosmonaute russe et un ukrainien et un
astronaute américain et cette mission
doit être réussie et on n'a pas d'autre
moyen de ramener les couches de notre
soutien merci beaucoup michel tonini
pour votre témoignage et vos
explications astronautes partis deux
fois dans l'espace ancien responsable du
centre des astronautes européens merci
beaucoup c'est est l'invité de paris
direct